i woke up i'm looking for a rim i
wouldn't have marinated
i thought i flew down toward the night
before i was so drunk so you know when
you're drunk and it was hints and i'll
drink hennessy anyway
so i knew i was like yeah i'm a marine
gone oh i ain't getting that bad
i don't like a lot of girl yeah you
won't believe that what's up gq it's
your boy look at you watching on the
rocks
[Music]
i gotta be honest man yeah the whole
family individual
before been doing this for years and
years and years and years and years
before been popping
up in my mind they got the best jury
other folks are they own like you've
heard me
to me i think they got the best jury i
just like how they hit me
snake have you ever seen young thor
snake pen that he got on his birthday
they made it something similar like that
like all right i like the snake pink i
just described me
i came from the south side i'm slime
snake i got snakes all around this one
then i bite you ain't trying 20 more got
snakes all around
then you got the cuban one for the 60
ball
i got the cardio two-tone with the
boogers on top and the
inside of the face this one got
different colors like a peacock that's
what i call it pink hats
got different colors they got the
cardigan bracelet
the bracelet they're about 15
right here see this one on this one
thirteen
only got two cardio braces on it really
help you drip out when you got this on
you they throw it down help you drip out
basically
[Music]
which is your favorite which is the most
special one that you have on give me and
it's the avionics
cutter you pokemon looking out from when
i first started correcting for me tommy
joe
dylan hey cousin everybody they've been
looking out for me
since i first started rapping right now
i'm getting this chain made with ivy on
jewelers
it's the king hood baby train they got
pacifier all over it
uh my second favorite one is the shader
baby
i'm gonna one gave me this on before my
album dropped he gave me this in the
studio
came out nowhere with a big-ass jury but
put flash on him i'm like yeah
i really want to get back the gunner to
go put slimy and [ __ ] because he want to
put slime and shade on the back
because it's like where he is i'm not
from shady park i'm from cunningham road
gunner for shady park so these look like
they look similar i'm a shader babe but
i'm not from shady palm slimy shady
gun like he got like a godfather
relationship with me like he make sure
everything
i do like that get done right i met him
on cleveland
though he came with your thought to the
part i was adding this to my song
superstar status then that day we're
going to a little event that'd be
happening every year like each 11 day
we're going to i wrote him an easter
monday
and after that day after he did tell him
to pull up on he came got him a song at
the studio
and ever seen them just been locked in
gun the thought they drilling ain't
tripping
they have water so i got all drift from
like
y'all think about he been rapping 10
plus years so he got
a lot of jury from like wrist game day
like he just got a lot of gear
gunner got a lot of jury now like seeing
dribble drunk
unfortunate jury then we'll have real
jim
baby goddamn who will
um pluto future future got now driver
gang got down
his trip injury gained trip and money
back
money back i was really a juror
[Music]
beverly hill uh jason like he made my
grills for me for my birthday last year
they roll gold i ain't wanting to go and
i dance when they want no ice not great
because i see everybody
i start grilling them up get turning you
don't clean them right i've been saying
a lot of people i just like grilling
them
but they don't have them for a long time
i'm gonna be black so i ain't want no i
just agree i go regular slug
rogo i'm gonna go veneer soon i want to
go veneer
but i don't even i don't want a
permanent grill permanent grill you've
seen like a lot of people when they took
their grills out they t black they got
cranky
hey i want my top shelf gotta change
bruh if i get my top shell gotta try and
go with no
i'll put my chains up i just what that
okay like i wanted this big
and just to have me like just sit on
them i had my hood baby chained but it
broke i had a hood baby i had a
guy chain iviana made me i got a chain
with three-tone it was gold rose and
white
but i gave it to my son on his birthday
he lost him
i ain't seen him once and then i had my
hood baby train that
wife had made but i was in l.a playing
around
where i'm broke i don't know how to help
like broken hair
i just got the head part i lost the hood
and the baby part actually got the face
my face
part i don't like so many rings i bought
like two rings
and then probably the next day i got
drunk at night
like that i won't drink i don't drink i
don't know myself and i got drunk that
night so
i woke up i'm looking from rim i
wouldn't have raised it
i thought i flew on tour the night
before i was so drunk i thought
i told you so you know when you drinking
it with hints and i'll drink hennessy
anyway
so i knew i was like yeah marine gone oh
i ain't getting that back
i don't like saliva you won't believe
that the jewel out here um
baby jason i had about two rings i had
about a gold
i started ring and i bought all white i
stopped ringing i had about a gold i
stopped knife
ring to go on top of the gold ring and
another i stopped knife ring to go on
top of that one
i lost i don't um playing a water fight
with everybody in the next day i lost
all the ring i said my god damn
i just can't wear rings i don't wear
rings i don't wear my only one
because i lose them don't get low
but like watching this they're not
getting low they ain't losing weight but
rings you're not really too much think
about them
you'll forget you got rings i on a rich
man
goddamn i pat it i want to do something
too i want to go over
i feel like everybody going to get a
rich man i got them paddy i got that ap
doing but
ain't not everybody going to do it they
just get just buy i'm gonna do it too
much
like so hard shame i'm taking right that
i'd be in it
and do my issues to it
[Music]
it's your boy top shell got it man shout
out to avian jewels man
shout out gq for heaven man y'all tune
in